our next our next speaker is zoran yang
zoran is a phd candidate princeton
uh he's the vmware research fellow in
the reinforcement learning program
hi um this talk is about uh exploration
in policy grading methods
and recently there are many successes of
policy grading methods
such as alphago and alpha star for
solving the game of gold
and starcraft respectively these
successes all require gigantic amount of
data
which make these methods unrealistic for
problems
where data acquisition is costly so
to achieve some proficiency we need to
address the fundamental
exploration and exploitation trade-off
so the goal of this work is to design a
new policy optimization algorithm that
is probably
some coefficient so our setting is the
standard episodic mdp the mdp consists
of h time steps
at each time step the agent observes the
current state of the system
and takes an action according to its
policy
and then receives a reward and moves to
the next state according to the markov
transition kernel
here the transition is unknown to us and
when the episode
and when the episode ends the agent pla
plays a brand new episode again and
adjusts its policy
so the policy of the agent is a mapping
from the current state
to the distribution of ac to the
distribution over actions
which specifies how the agent takes it
takes an action at each
at each time step and the goal is to
learn the optional policy which
achieves the maximum value of the
expected total return
so technically the questions we want to
address is how many episodes agents need
to play
so as to learn the optional policy
approximately
so next slide please
so the the algorithm we propose is an
optimistic modification
of the proximal policy optimization with
them it consists of two steps
first we solve a policy evaluation
problem by estimating
the value function associated with the
current policy
this is achieved by solving a least
squares regression problem
using all the historical data as the
training data
and moreover a key step is to add an
additional bonus function to the
solution of the least square problem
so as to ensure that the obtained
estimator is always the upper bound
of the ground truth element element-wise
then based on the optimistic value
function
we solve for the new policy by taking a
mirror's mirror decent step
which corresponds to solving a kl
divergence regularize the problem
and the solution can be obtained in
closed form
this algorithm is is a general
algorithmic recipe in the sense that it
can readily incorporate
many function approximation tools such
as kernel functions linear functions and
neural networks etc
and exercise please and finally in terms
of theory
we establish the sample complexity for
achieving
any epsilon accuracy which is given by
this upper bound
and here the the the dim the dimension
is the intrinsic dimension of the
problem so if we use
if our mdp can be embedded in a linear
space
then this dimension is a dimension
dimensionality of the feature
if it's embedded in the kernel space
then this dimension is the effective
dimension of the kernel space
and so this upper bound shows that our
algorithm achieves
some coefficient sample efficiency
properly
and that concludes my talk thank you